vos étudiants qui étaient ici et
maintenant c'est le drapeau ukrainien
au lieu de
bien
la statue de Katarina ce n'est pas juste
comme Monument c'est un énorme symbole
il est utilisé pour Poutine dans les vidéos dans certains
discours vieux trucs ce que Poutine fait maintenant elle le fait
comme 200 300  il y a des années et maintenant nous
pouvons voir comment les Russes font cela, nous pouvons
comprendre voulez-vous voir
le théâtre de Poutine dans 2000 ans après cette guerre
Je n'ai
pas besoin de euh dictateurs en
Ukraine euh comme les bâtiments publics l'
architecture publique avec le
pays démocratique  et nous voulons faire et
construire une statue de Nos Héros
[Musique]
uh
um
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
comme vous allez et comme le mettre sur
c'est le nouveau nom de la rue c'est
a Borussia Clark Street c'est un chef de la
fondation caritative à Odessa
est la
technologie l'
année dernière dans le même temps il était
presque presque impossible d'entendre la
langue ukrainienne juste dans les rues
donc les gens se parlaient entre eux c'était
très inhabituel mais maintenant
beaucoup plus  les gens parlent des jeunes ukrainiens
ils ne sont pas seulement en colère ils n'écoutent pas
la musique russe ils ne
regardent pas de films russes mon fils il a
11 ans et quand nous avons eu
cela le 9 mai Odessa a été
attaqué et nous avons entendu un très  de grosses
explosions et j'avais très très peur je
le tenais juste comme ça et il a
dit maman tu as peur j'ai dit j'ai tellement
peur et il a dit oh d'accord si tu as
peur imagine comment Moscou brûle
bien sûr je ne lui apprenais pas
mais c'est dans leur sang
euh
étranger